ti starai chiedendo cosa ci facciamo io
e berlino sotto al letto
beh lascia che ti spieghi
forse è meglio se esco fuori dal letto
così posso spiegarti meglio ho solo
paura che spunti fuori all'improvviso la
rai chiedendo di cosa o di chi sto
parlando
ora ti spiego subito ok aspetta che esco
fuori da qua però fa il silenzio berlino
mi stava proteggendo perché ho trovato
questo sotto alla porta ora lo
analizziamo bene c'è un disegno
inquietante qua dietro c'è scritto ti
sto osservando firmato dietro questo
disegno in cui tantissimo di questa
bambina o bambola ma buffon è molto
inquietante
quindi ho deciso di nascondermi sotto al
letto beh allora merlino si sta
nascondendo sotto al letto farei ci
penso forse al meglio chiudere la porta
casomai
detto
ok ora va meglio cosa è stato avete
sentito che faccio però la porta non mi
fido molto
ristoro
andrea ha lasciato un biglietto vediamo
cos'è
c'è scritto se la scelta sbagliata farai
non perderai è traccia in questo disegno
che cosa vuol dire secondo voi questo
disegno
questo è il primo indizio per riuscire a
scappare da annabella bentornati su
anita stories a grandissima richiesta
nuovo video interattivo come funziona
questo video ci saranno una serie di
indovinelli ed enigmi come questo quindi
iniziate a ragionarci sopra cui voi
dovrete fare le scelte io non potrò
darvi nessuna soluzione sarete voi a
fare le scelte e in base alla scelta che
farete potrete vincere o perdere gli
appariranno 2 caselline una destra e una
sinistra
a volte può anche apparire una in più
voi dovrete scegliere la casellina una
volta scelta cliccate sulla casellina e
la storia continuerà in base alla scelta
che avete fatto alla fine potreste
vincere questa challenge perderla ma se
perdete poter iniziare da capo e
riprovare alla fine sotto questo video
potete scrivere in quanti tentativi
avete vinto questa challenge scappa da
un bel e volete un altro video
interattivo lasciate un bel mi piace
perché questo leader aggiunge il 40 mila
mi piace ci sarà un altro video
interattivo
anzi scegliete pure voi il prossimo
personaggio votando nel sondaggio qui ho
qui in più lo scorso video interattivo
l'escape room del demo gorgone e quasi a
40 mila mi piace stare raggiunge il 40
mila mi piace ci sarà un'altra escape
room interattiva quindi dopo questo
video
andate a vedere o rivedere con l'altro
video interattivo sì potete lasciare un
mi piace e se volete potete anche
rigiocare siete anche inviare questa
sala giochi vostri amici e vedere se
loro riescono a vincere o meno tentativi
di voi quindi prima di voi o se voi
siete riusciti a vincere prima dove
dovrò andare per continuare per non
essere presa da una belle per scappare
d'anna
belle scegli una delle due cappelline mi
raccomando pensaci bene perché se fai la
scelta sbagliata potresti anche perdere
subito quindi dove vado scegli una delle
due case di linee